[Music]
this is CJ she's ambitious and I know I
couldn't have a better person to help me
negotiate with each row and company
other than you me I I would love to
serve this is Casey he is not I'd have
to be an idiot to mess this up
she's stressed out you took my dog no
it's not our dog it's my dog he doesn't
have a care in the world got a job
interview today how do I look you know
like a divorced alcoholic is this the
very world forever
how did this happen how's the brakes
lady I don't swap bodies every day well
I'm a career minded woman and I have a
lot going on during them I can't go to
work like this now they must walk in the
other person's shoes I'll be you and you
be me and that's it they must pretend to
be each other
discuss faces less sensitive to not legs
in the end they'll realize the grass
isn't always greener on the other side
this is a nightmare
ice beer milk presents Ella Jordan
Jimmy Custis Gunnar Willis KT Geralt and
Erica Manny in a film directed by Tim
Morton body swap anything you found an
M&M under your booth oh I wondered where
that went
you